blutiges geiseldrama am tegernsee es war
1924 als am dienstagabend bei der
polizei tegernsee ein notruf einging
nachbarn hatten den lauten streit
zwischen einem ehepaar gehört und den
notruf gewählt
wie die polizei berichtet soll ein 40
jähriger seine 25 jährige ehefrau in der
gemeinsamen wohnung erst als geisel
genommen und später erstochen haben
dann der not zugriff durch die polizei
doch da war es zu spät der täter hatte
seine ehefrau zu diesem zeitpunkt
bereits erstochen
die einsatzkräfte aufgrund dieser
massiven bedrohung dann die wohnung
betreten und wurden dann selbst ziel
eines angriffs gegen wegen eines
angreifers eines männlichen angreifers
der angriff also die kollegen massiv
attackiert und die kollegen haben sich
dann unter zuhilfenahme eines
polizeilichen schusswaffengebrauch
gewährt täter wurde hierbei getroffen
und ist in den folgenden folgen
schussverletzung verstorben die
staatsanwalt münchen 2 und das
bayerische landeskriminalamt ermitteln
jetzt die hintergründe der tat
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren